on suarez perkins merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france les premières
vaccinations donc c'était aujourd'hui
new yorkaise une une fierté pour vous
non pas du tout je pense que le
processus a été bien trop rapide qu'on a
trop insisté sur l'importance du vaccin
et j'ai bien peur que ce vaccin rentrer
dans des plans futurs du gouvernement à
différents niveaux pour dégoter un
contrôle bien plus important sur le
dépassement et les hanches à de la
population et qu'il y aurait un jet de
passeports de santé serait la différence
entre discussions de première place et
de se rendre place c'est très
préoccupant pour corps pour moi et je
pense que la sainte et ne justifient pas
cela et j'en suis certain une fois que
le gouvernement a le contrôle à ce point
alors on ne peut plus repartir en
arrière je suis très inquiet dice
perkins porte bien qu'on comprenne c'est
à dire il y aura ceux qui ont les moyens
de se faire vacciner et les autres on a
on n'est pas sûr de comprendre de cette
idée de votre justement votre inquiétude
entre les citoyens de seconde zone et
les autres si on a un passeport de santé
10 ans ont été vaccinés alors on devient
un train de première classe où on peut
se déplacer même un niveau interne à
turin on l'a et les restrictions ne
s'appliquent pas à vous à l'avenir car
vous avez ce transport si on ne se fait
pas vacciner alors le gouvernement peut
imposer des restrictions
aujourd'hui comme à l'aplomb et il leur
suffira de nos petits airs il ya une
augmentation du nombre des
contaminations et donc les personnes son
passeport ne peuvent plus faire ceci ou
cela et donc très bientôt l'uranium
campagne afin de pousser
gens qui n'ont pas été vaccinés à le
faire le vaccin deviendra obligatoire
est ce qu'ils ne se feront pas vacciner
oui en face à des conséquences très
graves dont des restrictions à leur vie
peut être même aller jusqu à la traîne
de l'or à la lumière l'idée est que si
l'on n'a pas été vaccinés contre une
maladie qui tue créé très peu de gens je
suis l'un d'eux jean collin l'idée donc
cette vaccination ce vaccin pourrait
être obligatoire et qu'il pourrait y
avoir des conséquences légales en cas de
refus c'est très préoccupant pour moi
vous c'est en quelque sorte rendre la
vaccination obligatoire qui vous pose
problème c'est un problème tout
simplement de liberté individuelle la
liberté publique qui se pose aujourd'hui
clairement se retrouvent en situation
très difficile
la production de ce vaccin utilise je
crois les morceaux de les avorter et je
pense que pour cette raison de large
partie des américains décideront mais
pour des raisons de religion de ne pas
utiliser ce vaccin kaffrine a été
produit avec des marchés qui les a
portés de fond de reprise et pelé des
raisons religieuses encore je suis
désolé effectivement c'est compliqué
pour nous de vérifier ce genre
d'allégations parce qu'évidemment la
plupart des personnes et d'ailleurs y
compris les scientifiques en france non
n'ont pas eu à les communiquer à ses
fameuses études scientifiques y sont
publiés dans les revues on ne les a pas
eu donc c'est vrai que c'est très
compliqué de vérifier ce genre
d'information une chose est sûre c'est
que donald trump que vous supportez que
vous soutenez lui voilà se targue
d'avoir mis en place ce vaccin sans lui
il le dit n'y aurait pas eu de vaccins
avant cinq ans vous partagez ce
diagnostic
du président sortant je pense que donald
trump autant se faire cette colle donc
je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui cela ne
suffit pas je ne soutiens pas aux
rideaux politique est en train de se
retrouver devant ma porte et me disais
je dirais monsieur le président faites
sous préfet je ne me ferai pas vacciner
pour une série de raisons et en
appartement en aucune mais il y en a
d'autres
par exemple ces théories du concours que
vous avez entendu
et moi je n'ai pas effectivement
l'information pour le trouver où la
valider certaines personnes disent que
ce vaccin permettrait de 2,2 ce terreau
entre les gens c'est à dire de les
empêcher de faire des enfants
et afin de réduire la population au
niveau planétaire il yad'autres et
théories du complot qui vise par exemple
qu'il s'agirait d'un plu trade et des
maladies à l'avenir non car cela
changerait les corps il ya beaucoup de
questions et je ne veux pas croire en
leur temps ce qu'on propose mais je vais
prendre le temps de faire des recherches
d'être certain que l'on me faire
vacciner n'irait pas à l'encontre de ma
conscience pour le moment je ne suis pas
assez informés pour prendre cette
décision pour décider de me faire verser
moins encore beaucoup de questions sur
ce vaccin et vous exprimer certainement
le doute de plusieurs de vos concitoyens
en attendant donc des des études plus
fiable c'est en tout cas ce que vous
nous dites dave perkins persie d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir